let me state the obvious the situation
in Greece is very fluid we've had ups
and downs but a real intensification as
talks broke off but in the weekend and
this referendum has been called we've
had the the Greek state going into
arrears with the IMF yesterday so and
obviously the bank holidays there so
without question in Greece the situation
has intensified and as a product of that
it raises the possibility of some
contagion more broadly into European
economies and within financial markets
so that's the overall risks and our job
is to worry about risk it also is to put
in place the protections against those
risks and it won't surprise you that we
knew that there was this possibility and
we have been preparing for it now so why
is the the direct impact on the United
Kingdom small well first thing is
there's very little exposure of UK banks
to two Greek entities including the
Greek state secondly there's there's
hardly any activity of Greek banks here
in the UK it's tiny relative to our
economy and thirdly we have been working
with our European partners in part to
help them put in place over the last
number of years much more protections to
prevent that so-called contagion that
jumping of risks in Greece into the core
of continental Europe through improving
the banking system through improving the
toolkit for the European Central Bank
and other facilities for European states
to draw on to limit limit this contagion
and that time has been well spent those
defenses are quite strong they might be
tested in coming days and weeks and
months but there are good reasons to
think not just that the direct exposure
to Greece is quite low but this indirect
route can be managed it looks this
morning or so the Greeks may have
compromised
to an extent do you take encouragement
from that presumably the best thing
would be if we could revive some sort of
deal and not have a referendum
weekend well it's as I say it's a
fast-moving situation it is in the best
interests of all the parties to come to
an agreement both the Greek authorities
and in the European authorities and
we'll do whatever we can to help that
and we certainly urge them to do so but
it's complicated it's complicated by
past decisions it's complicated by the
facts on the ground it's complicated by
issues around debt and the structural
reforms we don't want to get in the way
of those discussions and what we would
just encourage them to move to
conclusion as quickly as possible
without getting too technical what are
the contingency plans that you've drawn
up to limit contagion well one of the
one of the issues is just to make sure
that the Greek banks and and
subsidiaries that operate here in the UK
have the liquidity that that they need
to operate and if they don't that they
would they would be be be shot and so
for the Greek banks that's the
responsibility of the Greek authorities
we have some oversight of them and we
have oversight of liquidity and their
liquidity is held here at the Bank of
England so we take those
responsibilities for the Greek there's
one's Greek subsidiary banking
subsidiary operates here we're their
supervisor so we've made sure over the
last few years they have a lot of
capital a lot of liquidity and we have a
good daily view into all of that and and
so those aspects of heightened
monitoring and oversight and management
that is in place for the Greek banks we
coordinate with the Greek authorities
and the European authorities for the
subsidiaries our direct responsibility
just to be absolutely clear so there's
that element of it secondly there are a
series of conversations that we have
with the European Central Bank other
European banking authorities that with
the Treasury here and by the Treasury
European treasurer's to make sure that
broader contingency plans are ready and
and and those contingencies could be put
in place if necessary quite frankly they
haven't been necessary because we
haven't seen this spillover of the risks
in Greece into into broader financial
markets or into broader Europe but again
our job is to make sure that they're
ready I don't really want to
go through all the technicalities of
that not just because it's too technical
but also it makes them less effective
but you can be assured that we have been
preparing for this possibility and thus
far the coordination both here in the UK
in my view is exemplary and with our
European partners is what you would
expect is there anything you would have
done differently had you been in Mario
Draghi issues over the last few weeks
that there's nothing I would have done
differently if I've been in issues over
the last few years no I think President
Draghi in his colleagues have have very
importantly put in place not just
specific decisions but the actual tools
that they've put in place their ability
to buy sovereign bonds their bill in
order to provide stimulus to the
European economy just as the Bank of
England did several years ago provide
stimulus to this economy that's hugely
important but also the ability to take
action to protect the so-called
integrity of the euro to to ground
action in in keeping the euro together
that's a hugely important because people
in financial markets know that they will
act and the consequence of that is is
not to speculate against challenges
within the Europe so he's he and his
colleagues have done the right things
they have worked very hard to continue
to provide liquidity to the Greek
banking system they continued to do that
they haven't been increasing but they've
continued to provide liquidity so we're
fully supportive of the actions that he
and others that the ECB have taken now
I've seen the financial stability report
published today Greece is only one of a
number of potential risks to the system
that you outline I almost came away with
the impression that we should be more I
worried about China than Greece well I
think the China obviously second largest
economy in the world our banks and this
is a good news story you have much
greater exposure to China than they do
to Greece they just give you the numbers
if I may the Greek Greek exposures about
1% of their common equity Chinese
exposure is three and a half times their
common equity Chinese and other emerging
markets I should say I should be clear
it's a broader set now that's a good
thing because that's faster part a
growing part of the world and as part of
being global banks but it does me
that slowing Chinese economy a
restructuring in the Chinese economy
which is what is happening right now has
some implications through our financial
system and ultimately through demand for
a British product so it is important now
this is these are more medium term
issues Greece's you know this the
crystallization of wrist around graces
is an immediate issue it's changing by
the hour we're very focused on that
issues in China are more to the
medium-term they're more related to the
opening up of that economy the
development of that economy but yes in
the fullness of time
China's absolutely more in an order of
magnitude of magnitude more important
than developments on the periphery of
Europe now another risk that you've
mentioned is in the housing market and
specifically the buy-to-let market the
policy responses required here to calm
down that market that go beyond the Bank
of England's remit well a year ago we
sat down and and we had taken some
measures on owner-occupied housing so
you know that element of the market what
we and what we had done there was to
take out insurance we hadn't restricted
things that were actually happening but
we had taken measures to in effect
prevent banks from doing what they
normally do in the past which is to move
from responsible underwriting standards
to reckless underwriting standards and
we all end up paying for it in the end
so we've taken out insurance against
that owner-occupied and we've kept that
insurance in place and that's the right
thing to do and we've seen some positive
developments in the housing market as
consequence of that then at that time we
decided not to take measures against
buy-to-let partly given the relative
size that buy-to-let partly because of
the better underwriting standards at the
time and vital that variety of factors
we have we've discussed it again at this
meeting and we again decided not to take
any action we could take action with
respect to buy-to-let because it is
within our remit if there's an activity
that could affect financial stability
United Kingdom we can make
recommendations to the relevant bodies
to take action in fact that's what we
did a year ago with owner
you find we made a recommendation we
didn't have direct responsibility we
made a recommendation to the PRA which
is a group that regulates the banks and
the FCA which regulates sort of non-bank
providers of mortgages and that worked
and so if we needed to do something for
buy-to-let we could make a
recommendation the judgment of the
committee is we do not need to do
something at this stage right now you
also talked a lot about misconduct among
banks a couple of weeks ago
mansion-house you were indicating that
you thought the relationship between the
banking sector and society should be
reset and yet in the financial stability
report it points out that there is deep
mistrust towards the banking sector
particularly from SMEs well essentially
Ian when I you know one of the pleasures
of this job is I get to go around this
country and meet businesses and people
throughout the United Kingdom I have to
say in every region every time I go
outside the City of London which is
frequently one of the questions I'm
asked is about the banking system it's
often quite blunt why haven't certain
you know why haven't bankers gone to
jail what's going on in the city there's
a series of scandals and and and the
reality is that this this series of
misconduct has undermined trust in the
system and it's overshadowed what is a
very good news story which is the
improvement in the capital liquidity the
overall strength of the banking system
and a good news story which is
incredibly relevant to what we've been
discussing in terms of risk from Greece
or China or the housing market it
matters that our system is stronger so
we have to fix this we have to fix these
issues and with respect to misconduct
and it the answer isn't just to find the
institutions there have been huge fines
30 billion pounds worth of fines on UK
institutions that's equivalent to all
the capital they've raised in privately
since 2009 it's about shifting greater
responsibility to individuals - so I'm
able to have better answer those
questions that I hear around the country
why have an individual's taken
responsibility for the mistakes that
have been made not just mistakes but
outright misconduct in these
institutions and and mansion-house and
the associated reports around that show
way to rebalance responsibility to
individuals so that we have a a system
that merits the trust of the people now
in the report you call for more
monitoring of cyber risks and an
improvement of resilience in the system
do you think the current financial
system is sufficiently resilient to
withstand cyber attack no well you know
I think that any complacency like that
is is a recipe for that risk
crystallizing in other words you this is
a constantly evolving risk these whether
it's state actors or or private
cyberattacks you you have to prepare for
them so what we've done is we've
developed along with industry a
penetration testing mechanism so a way
of testing the resilience of banks
including the Bank of England we've been
subjected to it but how well are you
protected against cyber risk and this
isn't just that I think the key thing
I'd leave you with is it's not just
about the technical aspect of it
technical defences is but it's it's how
senior management is seized with these
issues because you have to understand
the nature of attacks you have to build
not just resilience but your ability to
recover from attacks and you have to do
it constantly there has to be one of the
questions that the chief executive
officer and the board are constantly
asking themselves or you won't be ready
so we're trying to play our role in
helping that along but I wouldn't be
complacent at all about the resilience
of the system to cyber because as soon
as you become complacent itself defeat